Krylov quantum diagonalization หรือ KQD ย่อมาจากการแก้ปัญหา matrix eigenvalue
โดยการ project matrix ลงใน subspace ที่เตรียมบนคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม ซึ่งสอดคล้องกับวิธี Krylov ซึ่งเป็น
แนวทางที่ทรงพลังจาก linear algebra แบบคลาสสิก ตลอดวิดีโอนี้เราจะสำรวจว่าวิธี Krylov มีประโยชน์อะไร
และจะ implement บนคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมได้ยังไงและเมื่อไหร่
แล้ว วิธี Krylov คืออะไร สมมติว่าเรามี matrix H ที่เกี่ยวข้องกับปัญหาทางวิทยาศาสตร์หรือธุรกิจที่มี n แถวและ n
คอลัมน์ เราสนใจ eigenvalue ต่ำสุด e 0 และ eigenvector ที่สอดคล้องกัน psi 0 ให้กำหนด
เวกเตอร์เริ่มต้น v ซึ่งอาจได้แรงบันดาลใจจากโครงสร้างของ h หรืออาจสุ่มมาเลย Krylov subspace
อันดับ r ที่เราเขียนว่า k r ถูกสร้างขึ้นโดยการนำ h กระทำบน
เวกเตอร์เริ่มต้นนี้ r ลบหนึ่งครั้ง โดยเพิ่มผลลัพธ์ของการกระทำของ h แต่ละครั้งที่ตามมา
ลงในชุดของเวกเตอร์ที่ span นั่นคือ kr คือ space ที่ span โดยเวกเตอร์ v
Hv H กำลังสอง และต่อๆ ไป เวกเตอร์เหล่านี้โดยทั่วไปจะไม่ตั้งฉากกัน
ในแบบคลาสสิกเรามักทำกระบวนการ orthogonalization ซึ่งคล้ายมากกับขั้นตอน Graham-Schmidt มากโดยเริ่ม
จากการ normalize เวกเตอร์เริ่มต้น V และเรียกผลลัพธ์ว่า V 0 แล้วสำหรับเวกเตอร์ถัดไป HV คุณลบ
การ projection ของมันบน V 0 ออกเพื่อให้สองเวกเตอร์ตั้งฉากกัน แล้วคุณ normalize ผลลัพธ์ คุณทำแบบนี้ต่อไป
กระทำด้วย H อีกครั้งและทำให้ผลลัพธ์ตั้งฉากกับเวกเตอร์ที่เพิ่มมาก่อนหน้าทั้งหมด จนกว่าคุณจะสร้างได้ R
เวกเตอร์ที่ orthonormalize แล้วที่จำเป็นสำหรับการ span Krylov subspace มิติ R
เมื่อได้ subspace นี้แล้ว คุณ project matrix ของคุณลงไปและ diagonalize matrix ที่ project แล้วที่เล็กกว่า มี
ความละเอียดอ่อนและการขยายความ แต่นั่นคือวิธี Krylov ในระดับที่ง่ายที่สุด
เพื่อให้เข้าใจว่ามันทำงานยังไงได้ดีขึ้น ให้ดูตัวอย่างง่ายๆ ถ้า H เป็น matrix นี้และ V ถูกเลือกให้เป็น
เวกเตอร์นี้ เราก็เริ่มด้วยการ normalize V ในการสร้างเวกเตอร์ที่สองใน Krylov subspace เราใช้
H กระทำบนเวกเตอร์เริ่มต้นของเราหนึ่งครั้งแล้วทำให้ผลลัพธ์นั้นตั้งฉากกับ V 0
พีชคณิตนิดหน่อยให้ผลนี้สำหรับ V1
ไม่มีประโยชน์สำหรับ matrix ขนาดเล็กแบบนี้และโดยปกติจะไม่หยุดที่ Krylov dimension สอง แต่ถ้าเรา
จะ project H ลงบน Krylov space K2 ของเรา เราจะทำแบบนี้โดยใช้ matrix V
ที่มีเวกเตอร์ Krylov แต่ละตัวเป็นคอลัมน์ และ transpose conjugate ของมันที่มีเวกเตอร์ Krylov เป็นแถว แล้วเราจะ
ได้ matrix นี้
matrix นี้มีมิติต่ำกว่า matrix เดิมของเราในทางเทคนิค เห็นได้ชัดว่าการลดขนาดนี้ไม่มีประโยชน์ในระดับ
นี้ วิธีนี้มีไว้สำหรับการลดขนาด matrix ที่มีหลายพันหรือหลายล้านแถวและคอลัมน์ลงเหลือ
เพียงไม่กี่ แล้วทำไมวิธี Krylov ถึงมีประโยชน์ ปรากฎว่าการทำ operator
action ง่ายๆ นี้มักเป็นวิธีที่มีประสิทธิภาพสูงสุดในการเข้าถึงสถานะ eigenvalue ต่ำสุดหรือ ground state ของ matrix
operator มาทำให้ชัดเจนขึ้นอีกนิด แม้ว่าเราจะปล่อยให้บทพิสูจน์เต็มรูปแบบอยู่ในตำราที่แนบมา เราต้องการ
แก้ปัญหาในรูปแบบ h กระทำบนเวกเตอร์ x ให้ค่าคงที่บางค่าคูณกับเวกเตอร์ x ให้เริ่มด้วย
การเดา eigenvector ของเรา x0 ซึ่งเป็นแค่คำตอบโดยประมาณ มัน error อยู่ซึ่งเราเรียกว่า e 0 ตอนนี้เราต้องการ
อัปเดตการเดานี้ซึ่งเราจะเรียกว่า x1 ซึ่งเราหวังว่าจะปรับปรุงการประมาณของเรา เราสามารถแสดงสิ่งนี้เป็น
x0 เดิมบวกกับการแก้ไขบางอย่าง p 0 ซึ่งยังไม่ได้กำหนด เรา
สามารถทำซ้ำกระบวนการนี้แบบ iterative โดยเพิ่มเวกเตอร์แก้ไข pi มากขึ้นเรื่อยๆ
เห็นได้ชัดว่าเราต้องการให้ error ของเราลดลง แต่มันไม่ใช่แค่สถานะที่เราสนใจ เรายังสนใจ
ผลของ h บนสถานะนั้นด้วย ดังนั้น quantity ที่เราต้องการ minimize จริงๆ คือ h-norm ของ error นี้ หรือ norm ของ
ผลของ h บน error นี้
ตอนนี้เราเห็นว่านี่คือ expression ที่เกี่ยวข้องกับ p 0 และเราสามารถถามตัวเองว่าการเลือก p ไหนจะ minimize
h-norm ของ error ได้มีประสิทธิภาพสูงสุด เราควรเลือกการแก้ไขจาก space ไหน ภายใต้เงื่อนไขบางอย่าง
เช่นเมื่อ h เป็น symmetric และ positive definite การเลือก r การแก้ไขแรกจากภายใน kr
ปรากฎว่าเป็นทางเลือกที่ optimal พูดง่ายๆ คือเราต้องการวิธีเตรียม subspace ที่ดีซึ่งเรา
สามารถ project Hamiltonian ลงไปได้ และในหลายๆ กรณี Krylov subspace คือ space ที่ span โดยเวกเตอร์ของ
การแก้ไขที่มีประสิทธิภาพสูงสุดสำหรับการเดาเริ่มต้นของเรา
สำหรับบทพิสูจน์จริงๆ ดูตำราที่แนบมากับวิดีโอนี้
ทุกอย่างที่เราอธิบายมาจนถึงตรงนี้สามารถทำได้แบบคลาสสิก แล้วเราจะใช้คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมได้ยังไงและเมื่อไหร่
สำหรับ matrix ขนาดใหญ่มากๆ วิธี Krylov อาจต้องใช้เวลาในการคำนวณนานและใช้หน่วยความจำมาก เวลา
ที่ใช้สำหรับ matrix operation ของ H บน V scale แบบ N กำลังสองในกรณีเลวร้ายที่สุด
และทำแบบนี้สำหรับทุกเวกเตอร์ที่เราต้องการใน subspace มิติ subspace R โดยปกติไม่ใช่ส่วนสำคัญ
ของ N และมักจะ scale แบบ log ของ N ดังนั้นการสร้างเวกเตอร์ทั้งหมดจะ scale
แบบ order N^2 log N
แม้ว่าจะมีขั้นตอนอื่นๆ เช่น orthogonalization แต่นี่คือ scaling ที่สำคัญที่ต้องจำไว้
การคำนวณควอนตัมทำให้เราสามารถเปลี่ยนว่าคุณสมบัติไหนของปัญหาที่กำหนด scaling ของเวลาและทรัพยากร
ที่ต้องการ แทนที่จะขึ้นอยู่กับขนาด matrix n ทุกที่ เราจะเห็นสิ่งต่างๆ เช่น จำนวน shots และ
จำนวน Pauli term ที่ไม่ commute ที่ประกอบกันเป็น Hamiltonian
มาสำรวจว่ามันทำงานยังไง
จำไว้ว่า operator ที่ time-evolve สถานะควอนตัมคือ exponential ของ iH หาร h-bar และ
เป็นเรื่องปกติมาก โดยเฉพาะในการคำนวณควอนตัม ที่จะตัด h-bar ออกจาก notation
วิธีหนึ่งในการทำความเข้าใจและแม้แต่ realize ฟังก์ชัน exponential ของ operator แบบนี้คือดู Fourier
series expansion ของมัน สังเกตว่า operation นี้ที่กระทำบนเวกเตอร์เริ่มต้น V ให้ผลรวมของ term ที่มี
กำลังของ H ที่เพิ่มขึ้นกระทำบนสถานะเริ่มต้น ดูเหมือนว่าเราสามารถสร้าง Krylov subspace ได้โดยการ time-evolve
สถานะ guess เริ่มต้นของเรา และนั่นก็เกือบจะถูก ข้อยกเว้นอยู่ที่
การ realize time evolution บนคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมจริงๆ term หลายตัวใน Hamiltonian จะไม่ commute กัน
ดังนั้น ในขณะที่ exponential operator ง่ายๆ บางตัวเช่น e ยกกำลัง negative i z สอดคล้องกับ
circuit ง่ายๆ แต่ Hamiltonian ทั่วไปไม่เป็นแบบนั้น และเนื่องจากมันมี term ที่ไม่ commute
เราจึงไม่สามารถ decompose exponential ให้เป็น product ของ exponential ง่ายๆ ได้แบบที่ทำกับตัวเลข ดังนั้น
สิ่งนี้ไม่ง่าย แต่เป็นกระบวนการที่ศึกษากันมาดีแล้วในการคำนวณควอนตัม เราทำ time evolution
บนคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมโดยใช้กระบวนการที่เรียกว่า trotterization ซึ่งในตัวมันเองเป็นเรื่องที่มีรายละเอียดมาก แต่ในระดับสูงมากๆ
โดยการแบ่ง time evolution ออกเป็นขั้นตอนเล็กๆ เช่น M ขั้นตอน เราจำกัดผลกระทบของความไม่ commutative ของ
term ให้เรียก Krylov subspace อันดับ r ที่เราสร้างในบริบทคลาสสิกโดยใช้กำลังของ h
โดยตรงว่า power Krylov subspace kpr
ตอนนี้เราสร้าง space ที่คล้ายกันโดยใช้ unitary time evolution operator u ที่กำหนดโดย exponential ของ iht
เราจะเรียก space นี้ว่า unitary Krylov space kur
power Krylov subspace kpr ที่เราใช้แบบคลาสสิกไม่สามารถสร้างได้โดยตรงบนคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม เนื่องจาก h
ไม่ใช่ unitary operator การใช้ unitary Krylov subspace สามารถแสดงให้เห็นว่าให้การรับประกัน convergence ที่คล้ายกัน
กับ power Krylov subspace
โดยเฉพาะอย่างยิ่ง ground state error จะ converge อย่างมีประสิทธิภาพตราบใดที่สถานะเริ่มต้น V มี overlap กับ
true ground state ที่ไม่ vanish แบบ exponential และตราบใดที่มี gap เพียงพอระหว่าง eigen
state ในที่นี้กำลังของ u กลายเป็น time step ที่แตกต่างกัน กำลัง k-th ของ u คือการก้าว
ไปข้างหน้าตาม time k คูณ dt
เราสามารถ label element ของ subspace ที่ time-evolve เป็นเวลารวม k*dt เป็น s sub k เราสามารถ project
Hamiltonian H ลงบน unitary Krylov subspace kur กล่าวอีกนัยหนึ่ง เรา
คำนวณ matrix element แต่ละตัวของ h ใน kur basis เราจะเรียก
projected matrix นี้ว่า h tilde matrix element ของ H tilde กำหนดโดย expectation value เหล่านี้ซึ่งสามารถ
ประมาณได้โดยใช้คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม
โปรดจำไว้ว่า H สามารถเขียนเป็นผลรวมของ Pauli operator บน qubit ที่ต่างกัน และ Pauli operator ไม่ใช่ทุกตัว
ที่สามารถวัดพร้อมกันได้ เราสามารถจัดเรียง Pauli term ให้เป็นกลุ่มของ term ที่ commute กันและวัดทั้งหมด
พร้อมกันได้ แต่เราอาจต้องการหลายกลุ่มเพื่อครอบคลุม term ทั้งหมด ดังนั้นจำนวนกลุ่มที่ commute แบบแยกส่วน
ที่ term เหล่านั้นสามารถแบ่งออกได้ ngcp จึงมีความสำคัญ ถ้าเราใช้ unitary Krylov subspace มิติ r
matrix ผลลัพธ์จะมีมิติ r คูณ r ถ้า r น้อยกว่า n มาก แสดงว่าเรา
คืบหน้าได้ดี และโดยปกติ r น้อยกว่า 100 มาก ซึ่งหมายความว่าเราสามารถ diagonalize สิ่งนี้ได้ง่ายๆ บนคอมพิวเตอร์คลาสสิก
แต่จำไว้ว่า s n และ s m โดยทั่วไปจะไม่ตั้งฉากกัน มัน
บางครั้งเป็นไปได้ที่จะ diagonalize matrix ใน basis ที่ไม่ตั้งฉากกัน แต่มีเหตุผลด้านตัวเลขและทางกายภาพ
สำหรับการเปลี่ยนไปใช้ basis ที่ตั้งฉากกันก่อน จึงแก้ generalized eigenvalue problem โดยใช้ gram matrix s
element mn ของ gram matrix กำหนดโดย inner product ของ s m บน s n
ทั้ง element ของ H tilde และ S คำนวณโดยใช้ Hadamard test
generalized eigenvalue problem จะกลายเป็นแบบนี้
ตามที่กล่าวไว้ข้างต้น มิติของ unitary Krylov subspace R เล็กกว่า initial
matrix dimension N ของเราแบบ exponential ดังนั้น value problem นี้แก้ได้ง่ายแบบคลาสสิก
สรุปคือ เราเริ่มด้วย reference state แล้ว evolve มันในช่วงเวลาต่างๆ เพื่อสร้าง unitary
Krylov subspace เรา project Hamiltonian ของเราลงบน subspace นั้น และยังประมาณ overlap ของ
subspace vector ด้วย สุดท้าย เราแก้ lower dimensional generalized value problem แบบคลาสสิก มาเปรียบเทียบว่าอะไร
กำหนดต้นทุนในการคำนวณของการใช้เทคนิค Krylov แบบคลาสสิกและแบบ quantum mechanically เราร่าง
สิ่งนี้ไว้แล้วสำหรับ version คลาสสิก และไม่มี analogy ที่สมบูรณ์แบบระหว่างแนวทางคลาสสิกและควอนตัมสำหรับทุกขั้นตอน แต่ตารางนี้รวบรวม
scaling ของขั้นตอนต่างๆ ไว้สำหรับการพิจารณา จำไว้ว่า Hamiltonian โดยทั่วไปมี term ที่ไม่สามารถวัดพร้อมกันได้เพราะพวกมัน
ไม่ commute กัน เราจัดเรียง term ใน Hamiltonian ให้เป็นกลุ่มของ Pauli operator ที่ commute กันซึ่งสามารถวัดพร้อมกันได้ทั้งหมด และอาจต้องการหลาย
กลุ่มเพื่อให้ครอบคลุม term ทั้งหมดที่ไม่ commute กัน การสร้าง H tilde บนคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมต้องการ
การวัดแยกสำหรับแต่ละกลุ่มของ Pauli string ที่ commute กันใน Hamiltonian และแต่ละกลุ่มต้องการ shots จำนวนมาก เราต้องทำแบบนี้สำหรับ R
กำลังสอง matrix element ที่แตกต่างกัน ซึ่งสอดคล้องกับ R กำลังสองการรวมกันของ time evolution factor ที่ต่างกัน
บางครั้งมีวิธีลดสิ่งนี้ลงได้ แต่ใน rough treatment นี้ เวลาที่ต้องการสำหรับสิ่งนี้ scale แบบ rough ตาม
จำนวน shots คูณจำนวนกลุ่มของ Pauli term ที่ commute กัน คูณ r กำลังสอง
element ของ s ต้องประมาณ ซึ่ง scale ตามจำนวน shots
ต่อ qubit กำลังสาม เราเห็นว่า quantum Krylov diagonalization อาจมีประโยชน์ในกรณีที่จำนวนกลุ่ม Pauli ที่ commute กัน
ใน Hamiltonian ค่อนข้างน้อย
การ dependency ใน scaling นี้ชี้ให้เห็นบางแอปพลิเคชันที่วิธี Krylov มีประโยชน์และแอปพลิเคชันอื่นๆ ที่น่าจะ
ไม่มีประโยชน์ Hamiltonian บางตัวมีความซับซ้อนสูงเมื่อ map ไปยัง qubit โดยมี Pauli string ที่ไม่ commute กันจำนวนมาก
ที่ไม่สามารถแบ่งออกเป็นกลุ่มที่ commute กันได้ง่ายๆ
มักเป็นเรื่องจริงสำหรับปัญหา quantum chemistry ตัวอย่างเช่น ความซับซ้อนนี้สร้างความท้าทายหลักสองประการสำหรับ
คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมในระยะใกล้ ประการแรก การประมาณแต่ละ element ของ H tilde มีต้นทุนในการคำนวณสูงเนื่องจาก
term จำนวนมาก ประการที่สอง Trotter circuit ที่ต้องการมี depth มากเกินไป ทั้งสองประเด็น
จะเป็นปัญหาน้อยลงเมื่อคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมถึงระดับ fault tolerance แต่ต้องพิจารณาในระยะใกล้ แม้แต่ระบบที่มี mapping ง่ายกว่า
กว่าปัญหาใน quantum chemistry อาจพบอุปสรรคเดียวกัน ถ้า Hamiltonian มี term ที่ไม่ commute กันมากเกินไป
วิธี Krylov มีประโยชน์มากที่สุดเมื่อ Hamiltonian สามารถแบ่งออกเป็นกลุ่ม Pauli ที่ commute กันค่อนข้างน้อย
และ H นำมาใช้ใน Trotter circuit ได้ง่าย เงื่อนไขทั้งสองนี้ตอบสนองได้
ตัวอย่างเช่น สำหรับ lattice model จำนวนมากที่น่าสนใจในฟิสิกส์ KQD มีประโยชน์เป็นพิเศษถ้ารู้เกี่ยวกับ
ground state น้อยมาก สิ่งนี้มาจากการรับประกัน convergence โดยธรรมชาติของมัน และความสามารถในการนำไปใช้ในสถานการณ์ที่
วิธีอื่นๆ ไม่เหมาะสมเนื่องจากขาดความรู้เกี่ยวกับ ground state
แม้ว่า KQD จะเป็น tool ที่ทรงพลัง แต่ด้านที่ใช้เวลานานของ protocol โดยเฉพาะการประมาณแต่ละ
element ของ projected Hamiltonian และ overlap ของ Krylov state แสดงถึงโอกาสในการปรับปรุง
แนวทางอื่นเกี่ยวข้องกับการประมาณ Krylov state โดยใช้ Trotter circuit แล้ว sampling
สถานะที่ประมาณแล้วเพื่อให้ได้ projection ลงบน computational basis จากนั้น project h ลงบน subspace
ที่ span โดย computational basis state เหล่านี้
ในกรณีที่นำมาใช้ได้ methodology นี้ที่รู้จักกันในชื่อ sampling-based Krylov quantum diagonalization หรือ SKQD
อาจเสนอการลดเวลาและทรัพยากรที่จำเป็นอย่างมีนัยสำคัญเมื่อเทียบกับ KQD แบบดั้งเดิม
การรวม Krylov subspace technique เข้ากับ sampling method ใน SKQD แสดงถึง frontier ที่น่าตื่นเต้นใน
quantum algorithm